bonjour à tous vous n'êtes sûrement pas
passer à côté du phénomène squid game la
série est un carton plein et je trouve à
juste titre et vu tous les petits non
dits les petits mystères les petits
secrets de squid game j'aimerais que
nous parlions ensemble de certains
points importants de la série et du coup
par extension déceler certaines choses
certains éléments cachés évidemment je
vais devoir spoil a serré pour pouvoir
la traiter dans la vidéo donc vous êtes
prévenus ne regardez pas cette vidéo si
vous n'avez pas vu sqweegel voilée est
ce que vous êtes prêts on y va s'il ya
bien quelque chose qui m'est restée en
tête à la fin de la série de squid games
est bel et bien l'organisation qui gère
ces fameux jeu là où nous sommes
habitués à avoir de grosse part de
mystère concernant le fond de la série
ou des véritables intentions des
antagonistes ici la fin nous explique
tout simplement que aux îles nam est
très riche et voulaient s'amuser et
qu'au final ce sont simplement des ultra
riches qui s'amusent avec des gens
endettés qu'ils considèrent comme des
animaux comme si ils pariaient sur une
course de chevaux cependant là où le
concept semble très simple pour que cela
fonctionne il faut une organisation avec
un protocole gérer avec précision et
surtout beaucoup d'argent sauf que en
soi si on réfléchit bas c'est toujours
pas suffisant et du coup tout laisse
porte à croire que l'organisation est
beaucoup plus profonde qu'on le croit je
vais m'expliquer prenons le cas des
policiers tous les participants sont des
gens au fond du trou endetté sur des
centaines de milliers voire de millions
de wons comme par exemple 5 go est
justement ce dernier est recherché par
la police pour être jugé par rapport à
son ancien métier sur 456 personnes
455 sont morts dans le plus grand des
silences c'est impossible pour la police
d'ignorer autant de disparition et
pourtant c'est ce qui semble être le cas
le plus frappant est la fameuse histoire
avec franck joon ho fameux policiers
infiltrés car ce dernier avant de
confronter son frère a réussi à
contacter son chef pour lui demander du
renfort et on ne sait pas s'ils
l'envoient à véritablement marché mais
il a envoyé des photos de tout ce qui se
passe là-bas à son chef or déjà je
préfère le préciser mais je suis sûr
qu'il n'est pas mort hinault s'est très
bien visé il tire une balle dans la tête
à chaque fois et là ils tirent dans
l'épaule de son frère c'est évidemment
pour ne pas le tuer après tout ça reste
son frère bref sauf que mort ou pas il
est censé quand même d'y avoir des
conséquences puisque avec les renforts
et les garde-côtes et l'emplacement
dévoilée par wang et bien son corps sera
forcément retrouver et s'il est vivant
ce qui est sûr pour moi eh bien il
dévoilerait tout à ses confrères
policiers et c'est là le problème car un
an plus tard nous apprenons que le
squeeze game recommence ce qui veut dire
que la police a fermé les yeux sur les
disparitions des participants perdant et
que les efforts de rangoun joon-ho n'ont
servi à rien alors est ce que au final
la police ne serai pas complice de
l'organisation ou plutôt acheter mais
attendez ce n'est pas fini car cela va
même encore plus loin et c'est même là
le plus intéressant la série est truffé
de détails qui apporte beaucoup au
scénario déjà dans son fonctionnement
c'est simple il faut une double lecture
pour avoir tout en main il faut revoir
la série pour voir tous les petits
indices qui montrait que aux îles nam
n'était pas un participant comme les
autres par exemple est bien là
j'aimerais que nous retournions sur le
dernier épisode de la saison quelques
temps après sa confrontation avec une
âme guillaume décide d'aller chez le
coiffeur pour faire sa fameuse coupe de
cheveux rouges et cette scène qui au
premier abord semble
no dig et qui marque une page qui se
tourne pour guillaume et bien possède un
détail très important c'est la télé et
encore ce n'est même pas tant que ça un
détail puisque la seine propose très peu
de dialogues aucune musique pour
justement dans la mise en scène mettre
en valeur le son de la télé ce qui
semble être une sorte de journal
télévisé coréen nous explique que
l'endettement des ménages a
considérablement augmenté et ne cesse de
grimper que c'est même la plus forte
augmentation parmi 43 pays et que tout
ça serait apparemment due à la levée des
restrictions concernant les prêts cela
peut sonner comme une théorie du complot
mais le profil des participants du
squeeze games est toujours le même des
gens qui sont sur endettés et qui à
cause de sa non plus d'argent et au
final perdre tout et deviennent des
personnes qui sont au fond du trou où la
vie en société devient un enfer au
quotidien et qui par extension n'ont
plus rien à perdre est ce que vous voyez
ce que je veux dire si vous n'êtes pas
endettée que vous êtes un citoyen lambda
qui n'a pas spécialement de problèmes
d'endettement et c est bien aucune
raison de participer aux secours games
et c'est là tout l'intérêt d'endetter
les gens car grâce à ça ils vont de même
vouloir participer ils seront
conditionnés à jouer sans remords et ils
voudront tenter leur chance de leur
plein gré et cela explique pourquoi
cette levée des restrictions pour que
justement des gens se fassent avoir et
tombe dans cette spirale infernale qui
va les conduire au squid game d'ailleurs
très peu de temps après ce reportage et
son passage chez le coiffeur
guillaume fait la découverte que le jeu
reprend et ce en corée et les missions
parlait justement de la corée autrement
dit l'organisation serait si puissante
et influente que l'état lui même serait
lié au projet pour pousser les gens à
l'endettement et donc créer des
participants pour le squeeze game avec
par extension une police
lié à l'état fermeraient les yeux sur
tous ces agissements une méthode cruelle
mais qui n'est pas sans raison aux îles
nam nous a prouvé qu'il ne croyait plus
en l'humanité et qu'il considère
certaines personnes comme des déchets
humains puant dans le fond c'est moins
de pauvres qui sont endettés pour la
création d'un nouvel ultra riches qui
sera apprécié par les banques et le pays
après tout tout est une question
d'argent idiot
non
[Musique]
pour continuer je me sens obligé d'en
parler car c'est vraiment la théorie
phare du moment où il n'a mme serait le
père de guillaume et j'avoue que je suis
plutôt mitigé car à la fois la série
sait ce qu'elle veut nous faire croire
comme vous le savez ce coup de gueule
mais très axé sur les détails il y a
même besoin d'une relecture pour
justement discerner tous ces petits
détails mais en même temps c'est
tellement gros voire presque tiré par
les cheveux la relation entre guillemets
il n'a m'a toujours été particulière et
ça on ne peut pas le nier il partage
beaucoup parlent ensemble se respecte
voir se protège et s'entraident et quand
on sait qu'il n'amenait pas un vrai
joueur cette relation perturbe encore
plus pour aller dans le détail la
première chose et qu'il n'est jamais
fait mention du père de guillaume dans
la série il vit seul avec sa mère le
père n'est jamais mentionnée comme s'ils
avaient été toujours absent bref la
possibilité que le père de guillaume
soit parti alors qu'il n'était encore
qu'un très jeunes enfants fonctionne car
du coup il ne se rappellerait pas de son
père et du coup il ne reconnaît pas le
visage dinh nam et cela peut marcher
ensuite si l'on se penche sur les
dialogues entre les deux personnages
guillaume affirme par exemple ne pas
supporter le lait car il ne le digère
pas et une âme réagi en lui disant qu'il
avait dû prendre pas mal de fessées et
guillaune affirme que c'était le cas et
se demande comment il sait il nomme
rétorque que justement son fils était
pareil et par extension il a dû lui
mettre des fessées et il ya plusieurs
détails comme ça comme la représentation
du quartier où il n'a m'affirme avoir
habité dans un quartier similaire et il
retrouve sa maison john affirme avoir
vécu aussi dans un même quartier il y a
aussi le coup de l'anniversaire du fils
dynam ou lui aussi comme guillaume doit
se racheter par rapport à sa fille il
nam doit offrir un beau cadeau pour son
fils car il avait oublié son
anniversaire enfin bref on peut aller
très loin comme ça avec tous les petits
détails mais au fond je ne trouve pas ça
si pertinent car au final cela peut être
tout simplement dû au hasard dans la
mise en scène cela pourrait être même
tout simplement des points communs qui
permet justement aux deux personnages de
se relier et de se rapprocher en
revanche il ya quand même des points
intéressants a souligné notamment la
venue dynam dans le quartier de
guillaume nous le savons maintenant ils
nam et l'organisateur du jeu est donc un
ultra riches qui ne sait plus quoi faire
de son argent pourtant il a fait la
démarche de rejouer son rôle de joueur
001 pauvres et à la toute fin de sa vie
hors du jeu pour aller à la rencontre de
guillaume échangé deux trois mots avec
lui il y a aussi le cas où ils montent
la garde la nuit il nam souhaite monter
la garde avec john et se retrouver seule
avec lui et encore plus intriguant c'est
la fin de la série puisqu'il nam sur son
lit de mort sa dernière volonté a été de
faire venir guillaune et partager un
dernier moment avec lui un dernier jeu
et lui raconter la vérité il n'a même
cherche le contact avec guillaume il
cherche à aller vers lui
néanmoins tout ça c'est pareil la
conclusion d'une âme et que malgré la
maladie malgré son ennui perpétuelle
parce qu'il a trop d'argent malgré sa
perte de foi en l'humanité il s'est fait
un ami dans le jeu il a trouvé son galbe
ou guillaume lui a prouvé qu'il existe
encore des gens bien malgré la situation
horrible dans laquelle il était et comme
le prouve la signification de genbu
guyonnet il nam étaient des amis qui
partageaient tous qui se sacrifiait pour
l'autre et c'est là la particularité de
leur relation en soit la théorie du père
pourrait exister mais au final qu'est ce
qu'elle rapporterait au récit la
succession du jeu semble plutôt revenir
à hinault l'agent d' in âme et surtout
il nam est mort guillaume lui a déjà
prouvé que l'espoir était toujours là
qu'il a eu raison le pauvre homme dehors
a été sauvée il nam a perdu
enfin pour conclure j'aimerais que nous
nous tournions vers l'histoire des deux
frères hinault semble être le digne
successeur de in nam et comme le montre
la fin de la série il a relancé le jeu
est déconseillé guillaune dirt
participer cependant si saison 2 il y à
pas mal de choses vont changer tout
simplement car hinault mais pas une âme
ce que je veux dire par là et vous allez
peut-être trouvé que j'abuse mais
l'histoire des deux frères possède une
énorme correspondance avec star wars en
fait hinault résonne comme un dark vador
il est le bras droit masqué du dirigeant
ultime il n'a même qui serait comme un
palpatine qui sans qu'on se doute est
dans la mêlée depuis le début ils jouent
un rôle où on le pense honnête et gentil
alors que c'est lui qui est derrière
tout ça bref et du coup concernant
hinault on retrouve vraiment les mêmes
codes que dark vador c'est lui qui
organise tout qui est au front il est le
dirigeant respecté de ses sbires alors
que le véritable patron est dans l'ombre
et là où ça m'a véritablement frappé
c'est lors de la confrontation avec son
frère à la manière de l'épisode 5 de
star wars i know révèle son identité
harangue en lui faisant comprendre qu'il
est son frère exactement comme dark
vador apprenant talent luke skywalker
qu'il est son père les deux antagonistes
tendent la main à leurs adversaires et
ces derniers ne souhaiteront pas les
rejoindre d'ailleurs tout comme l'udc il
y à cette symbolique huang s'est
incrusté dans l' empire de
l'organisation malfaisante et se fait
attraper par le dirigeant qui le
blessera non mortellement mais bref tout
ça pour vous dire que si l'on suit cette
symbolique hinault du coup symbolisée
par dark vador se retourneraient comme
lui comme il l'avait fait dans l'épisode
6 en fait son grand patron est mort et
la confrontation avec son frère lui a
coûté le fait d'avoir tiré sur son frère
hante hinault et si saison 2 il y a
l'histoire des deux frères continuera et
pourrait faire retourner la veste de
hinault bon après je sais que ce fruit
games inspire déjà de mangas comme kaiji
par exemple mais ce procédé
scénaristique est très populaire il
n'est pas là par hasard je me serve de
star wars pour justement cerner le
personnage mystérieux qu'est hinault
enfin voila je pense pas arrêté là je
pensais à la base vous proposer un trois
théories mais c'est compliqué de
discerner devrait théorie bien distincts
gdansk wegame la série plutôt composée
de petits secrets de petits détails
cachés qui permet justement une nouvelle
compréhension de la série et c'est
justement du coup ce sur quoi j'ai voulu
m'orienter bon maintenant il faut
attendre de savoir s'il y aurait une
saison 2 mais bon vu le succès
planétaire de la série le fait que
netflix est repris en main le projet je
pense qu on se mouille pas trop pour
dire qu'il y aura une suite je vous ai
proposé ma vision personnelle sur les
points importants que j'estimais de la
série à vous maintenant de me faire part
de vos perceptions et de tous les
détails qui vous ont marqués par exemple
l'épisode 6 était clairement une
dinguerie avec le jeu débit et je suis
curieux mais sur quels jeux vous pensez
que vous auriez pu le mieux vous en
sortir moi je pense que 1 2 3 soleil
aurait peut-être été mon point fort
enfin bref merci à tous d'avoir regardé
la vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour ne louper aucune des prochaines et
puis bah a laissé un petit pouce bleus
écoutez cet argot rock on se retrouve
très vite et que le lionheart allez
allez ciao tome
[Musique]